we're going to Greece oh yeah
[Music]
a lot has happened since My Big Fat
Greek Wedding
my father passed away and His Last Wish
was for us to visit his childhood
Village and reconnect with our Roots so
we're having a reunion we're going to
Greece oh yeah
[Music]
and by Lee I mean
the whole family who wants some lucky
paging so lucky anybody by the name of
sulaki on his flight
Aristotle what I didn't know you were
going to be here you're doing here I had
an amazing date
she ghosted him
[Music]
we are related to your Papa's Papa who
was married to my great great Yaya
sister sustaino
[Applause]
I will be your favorite
I promised my dad I would find his best
friends I know them do they still live
here no how do we find them they will
come for the reunion did they tell you
they're coming no
there's no other bedrooms family
sleepover
the one reunion
we'll never forget to
cheers man no I am surprised but I am
not surprised because I'm never
surprised
you lost me
[Music]
you dreamed about Aristotle last night
how did you know
Greek Voodoo bam I remember your story I
really need to find my dad's friends
Angelo and I are on it okay bye
in your eyes
I'm calling it you got us back to Greece
you're the head of the family now I
can't really Day drink like this don't
worry a lady is never drunk
it's the one we have for dinner oh thank
you uh I'm a vegetarian
no
[Music]
foreign